hello guys I'm Greg Tony Gilroy here
trees yacht Instagram instrumenting this
in the videos I'm sick right now
yeah I'm really sick a WonderCon all day
yesterday making much of annoying ass
dicks there
great some just joke it is fun but I
woke up very sick and but the show must
go on
the Christian Laird first one to say in
the lobby trailer drop-in sort of like a
million other people top talker is my
Bobby let's do this now man
[Music]
copter is running
[Music]
[Music]
it's an essential hidden for mm you
didn't assume it's very you
the Angus that she was named ominous
chosen to be a distinct tree but has
thirst for power let her down the darker
part one that had to discuss because of
your actions
this ancient power
husband
[Music]
you are alive because users whoa
Wow legend should be magical powers
I'm sure getting him to
[Music]
she won't stop until she has we made our
work hardware
- Wow
[Music]
simplification
you can't run
after only eruption
she's got plans for you
[Music]
wow wow wow wow that was before we
talked about this trailer I have I have
a comment to make okay The Mummy
watching all about to show you I mean
okay so the mommy
trailer one is way for this gonna Tom
Cruise here okay 43 seconds in trailer
number one all right okay trailer number
two
17 seconds yeah my 80 are that [ __ ] over
here what I think you just throw it and
really quick time Tom Cruise is like Jim
Baxter
driver now like that's what he says in
the first trailer very big diamond
I thought the trailer was better than
the first one well yeah gave you way
more to let go with cuz when you just
saw the mummy a peahen just go down to
destruction like okay this looks kind of
know Mike right off the bat but it looks
more like a mummy movie to me
yeah it's any more interesting to be
like okay he was chosen that's why I
like he will go when I saw the first one
I was like ah it looks like pretty good
move from the start and then like it
just loses it yeah but like this one
really feels like it could build into
like if they're really going to make
this a universal monster movie then it's
like gonna be a good start well like
just a kind of introducing one character
like this well to me the best parts of
the trailer but it's more like a horror
movie you know when there's like tension
and suspense and fearful so like when
he's being consumed by the rats and then
my mom used to come after him oratory to
where the girl gets pulled underwater
those are the best parts the parts of
the feel off to the air like the
action-adventure parts live urgent scene
cheesie's it's [ __ ] of it well I felt
like the guys how blast those scenes
because like
really smoky trailer trailer just to get
any like cooking this one really kind of
made me feel like I okay like this uh
plot for the movie just really seems
really in-depth when it goes to starting
off with my game the reveal of the mummy
and Russell Crowe talk about how to kind
of get more involved in really late I
Jekyll in there yeah you just got slip
them in yes what a man man we gotta let
people be known it's a universal monster
verse guess what we're gonna do we're
gonna wish you know about werewolves
yeah I mean I like the touches where it
feels like a mummy movie like when you
go to the past and then you see who this
character was yeah I mean that's her
what's why like I was wondering like how
they were going to put that one compared
to like how the old mummy movie are
stuff but this one it just looked like
she is just a dark woman just combing
crear people but who wants power she
wants power that's way down they always
want power but yeah I mean this movie
looks a lot darker like just the way
it's all laid we go dark this movie the
blade will explain this without audio
which is illegal a doctor no one could
stay away from tacos even the mummy
that's dish is like I chose you
okay I'm on the play exactly it
definitely has like strong cheesy
elements to it what is your mummy and
the mummy has cheese you know so far
about of loving I was kind of wonder if
it was gonna be like good amount of
humor like the other movies would have I
know this isn't like anywhere near like
how those movies work so I'm not
comparing like this program but I kind
of feel like they're gonna be good a lot
of times orders to it like kind of slip
in a lot of like cheesy moments that oh
yeah I would fit pretty good yeah well
it looks what I mean Tom Cruise is
always going to be running regardless of
flavor
oh yeah a Tom Curtis doesn't run it's
not a Tom Cruise movie I like the makeup
of design too there's a lot to
appreciate in the trailer I don't know
it looks like it's sort of trying to
build a mystery up like anyway you know
there's questions that you have like why
Tom Peters exactly chosen what is he
exactly chosen for there's a good
mystery by being billed Alex Kurtzman
the director has you know worked on
things that involve mystery and this is
also recovered and by Christopher
McQuarrie who did edge of tomorrow Jack
Reacher rogue nation so I mean there's a
whole good [ __ ] team behind this you
know
great team behind it our search has
worked on other Tom Cruise flicks as
well the thing about it though that that
still remains very evident for me is it
doesn't feel like The Mummy movie it
feels it still feels like Tom Cruise's
yeah yeah I mean when you put a
character in like that you wonder if
he's just going to steal the spotlight
to where it's like you really care about
it I mean Louie are you care that it's
another Tom Cruise movies it could
really play off that keen goes into like
these other movies and like a character
that could like be able to be in other
movies might not be in the small you
know that's why point though is I'm not
interested to see the mummy in the
monster verse what they do they're big
collab I'm like thinking oh they're
going to put Tom Cruise in a collab
video I'm not thinking they're gonna put
the mummy shake it there well yeah
that's what I'm thinking about this
movie is maybe he takes over the slide
of being like the moment up to the
moment he will like continue in these
movies or something like I was kind of
figuring that what's going to happen if
that's gonna be the case in this movie
then I'm really interested to see what
other characters they'll get for other
monsters not have time crews at the
spotlight in the Indies monster variety
because they're gonna have to have good
actors to kind of like shining the same
way as Tom Cruise in those other movies
it's gotta be fun man just calm cruise
running gun is doing his name
Tom Curtis like hey hey hi scriber the
real rejects where we kids Terry kills
trees on Instagram he's also the the
manager at Costco and not Hollywood all
all the column cost goes to the CEO of
Costco he makes three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year which is really
not a lot yeah for a CEO I kind of don't
even spend it I live like a boom you I
know
hey hey
hey little power I don't you talk about
I don't know I can't we're going to cut
it a thing about that man we get you
going